Hơn năm 2018, giữa khu dân cửa mắt quả tăng nhiều người đàn phía mà tuy.
Cuộc độ kịch giết ra tối 2 mi trình tháng 1, soar công man tình quả nãy phối hợp với cảnh sát biển
Bục tư lệnh vùng 2 thực hiện.
Câm đầu đừng dây là buổi văn thiện của mi bệnh tuổi, bị bắt cùng sống người liệt qua người ta hiện chường.
Theo cảnh sát, thiện có bà thiện án một tils yếu là dụt cái hình quốc tạp để chiếm giữ
hẹn phép của đất hơn một nghiệm nè quốc tại hôm Mỹ tân khu ví tế dụt của bật này được giao trảm bên ngoài, bên trong dưỡc nhà choi đau hôm chuẩn.
Đặt công tế nơi làm cho chữa nhiều trộn về cảnh được sự dụt đến buổi trang.
Tại đây, hiện cho những người nghiệm mà tuy đến hôm nhau, sự dụt mà tuyệt, đường lại họ phải kên gác,
hẹn dưới, đến lại tý có người đến người bán và tham gia các khẩn bị vi vì và bật khác như chỗ đắp về cảnh.
Để là tụi điểm phức tạp tại địa phương, vũ án đặc đừng mở giúp điều tra.